a small win today for the aclu of nevada  they are working to remove cannabis from  the nevada board of pharmacy  classification as a schedule one  controlled substance aclu nb says people  are still being arrested for possession  of weed based on the board of pharmacy's  inclusion so they're now suing on behalf  of antoinette poole a man convicted of  possession of a controlled substance  that being marijuana well today clark  county judge joe hardy denied the  board's motion to dismiss the  lawsuit they do have  standing  and that's  the general issue that i'm focused on  today  the substance of the  remaining arguments  will be addressed in  at the very least briefing  so no new hearing was set today however  based on the timeline laid out in court  by  the judge another hearing will likely be  set for august